hey what's up guys my name is Luciano
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we had a bit of a maintenance
episode we've fixed some things up and
moved some things around just to
organize hazel a little bit more check
out that video if you haven't already I
also talked a little bit about
maintenance in general and how to
approach that kind of from a software
engineers perspective today we're gonna
have a little bit of a look at what's
changed in the hazel repository because
in the last episode I kind of told you
guys that if you want to contribute to
hazel you can just open some pull
requests fix some warnings fix some
other things and there's a lot of stuff
that has actually happened throughout
the week which is really cool to see so
we'll kind of look through that a little
bit and the other thing I want to do is
kind of prepare hazel for 2d rendering
so what I mean by that is we basically
want to take the sandbox layer that we
have at the moment and kind of I guess
extend that or maybe even make another
layer so that we have everything we need
to kind of test the 2d renderer as we
start doing a so in other words I want
to create like an isolated test in a way
like a sandbox test for the 2d renderer
so that when we actually start working
on it hopefully next week or the week
after we'll be able to just get down
there a lot easier I'll be honest with
you guys this has been a very very busy
week for me I almost didn't want to
release an episode today but I thought
that if we just kind of look at some
issues and we kind of just move some
things around and set up a more kind of
I guess a more robust test case for our
2d renderer and they'll probably be a
little bit of a better use of that time
than just skipping this week's episode
in tile the first of all I just want to
thank all the patrons that make this
series possible patron accomplice -
they're shown are you guys will get
access to a whole bunch of stuff if you
help support the series including the
hazel development repository which is
basically a version of the hazel engine
that I've do up to my own time that has
like you know animated 3d pprn during
and just saw a whole bunch of stuff you
guys you guys should be familiar with
what it'll dev has I do want to make it
head into a video soon because I've
added a few other things to that such as
multi-threading for example so there are
some changes going on with that but as I
mentioned super busy week almost nothing
done to do with this kind of stuff this
week but but let's jump in and have a
look
you guys have done this way because
you've certainly been been busier than I
have and then we'll go ahead and
probably change up hazel and create that
new kind of lair for that 2d renderer
okay so this is this is kind of all the
commit history that's happened so I kind
of did this upgrade to Visual Studio
2019 with organizational and this is
everything that we did in the last
episode over here a week ago as you can
see and then today and this is kind of
all the stuff that's happened since then
so all that was kind committed four days
ago
lovely Santa who is one of the kind of
core hazel engineers I'll call him he's
a really cool guy who's been doing a lot
of the kind of moderation and also other
small tasks around hazel which is really
cool for example he actually wrote this
contributing to hazel document which is
really cool to see this is what you guys
should read if you want to contribute to
hazel there's a lot of stuff here which
is all really really good so definitely
take a look at that if you're interested
in actually contributing the
contributions in general I don't want to
talk about them too much I might make a
video dedicated about that but
contributions in general are very tricky
with hazel because obviously this being
an engine that I'm trying to write by
myself to show you guys how to write an
engine if - if there's too much work
that goes in from your side then that
makes it more difficult for me to
actually show how to build an engine if
you know what I mean so for example if
someone wrote a 2d renderer and they
were like here you know this is a 2d
renderer here's a pull request accept it
if I do that I can't just be like so by
the way someone added a tree to render
Lola because a lot of you might want to
actually see how to write a 2d renderer
how to integrate that into hazel how
that gets done kind of from scratch so
because of that it's really tricky with
this I've mostly limited this to just be
like fixes and minor like changes for
example you know there are obviously
little bugs that I've written other
things that you'll see here that will go
through this list that could have been
changed or could have been done slightly
better stuff like that is exactly what
Porto Corsa for example fixing compiler
warnings right which i know is not the
most satisfying thing to
on for you guys which is why feel free
to fork hazel and do whatever you want
with it right right or to you render a
write a 3d render up do whatever you
want and then you can share it hopefully
on discord with the rest of the
community the channel concise discord by
the way I'll have a link in the
description to that discord but feel
free to do stuff like that and then
obviously if one of you guys does write
like a full-on like two-tier and royal
thread around roll you do something cool
I'd love to kind of showcase that in a
video I've got no issues with that it's
just that when it comes to this kind of
hazel repository the master branch and
all about stuff I do kind of want to
keep that as something that we actually
work on throughout these videos I have
thought a lot about the future of hazel
because these videos are getting harder
and harder to make because you know
especially when it comes down to
designing and implementing a 3d render
on um Tilley is also bad but a 3d render
or like a UI system or like a post
processing system those are all really
quite large systems and for me to sit
here and type out all the code in front
of you like this is the kind of stuff
that would take an engineer a week of
full-time work to do out like a game
studio I had of like a software company
right this isn't something that I can
condense into like a less than forty
minute video for example so I think that
even though I love the live coding in
front of you guys fortunately I think at
some point we are gonna have to go back
to just looking at this and kind of
explaining how this works I might try
and do more on the OpenGL series side of
things where maybe like we'll write an
OpenGL based library and then on that we
can be like I can be like this is how
you write a fast
- Deeb a surendra in OpenGL right and
then you guys can kind of and that'll be
like kind of an in-depth video
potentially that will probably describe
a lot of the theory and then kind of go
through the implementation and that
might be more of like a learning
exercise where is this inevitably
unfortunately it's going to turn into a
project where instead of writing
everything line by line it's just gonna
be like so this is what we did this week
is what we did this week which I don't
know I don't know what to do like to be
honest you guys want to help me out in
the comments I'm I'm all he is because
you know writing a game engine line by
line in front of someone especially if
you don't have the bandwidth to kind of
do that everyday in the form of live
streams for example which I just can't
do it's a tricky one but anyway let's
not talk about that now let's look at
what what you guys have done in the past
week and then we'll kind of talk about
refactoring hazel as well if we get the
chance - okay so these are all the
commits as I mentioned before let's take
a look at these so stuff like whilst the
ones that I wanted to actually take more
of a look at because you guys can take a
look at this yourself you just go to the
hazel repository and then click on the
commits you'll see all the commits and
you can actually view the diffs
by just opening up the commit hash over
here and then you can see how that works
so this is a good one for example
automated platform detection using
predefined macros so in other words
compiled it's pretty fun macros based on
the platform or compilers being used so
for example on discord win32 is defined
when you're using MS PC on Windows and
your configuration is set to in 32 well
same was with 164 so that's actually
true for both architectures but this
one's obviously only true for x64 if
that's not defined we can assume that
we're trying to do an x86 build which is
a supporter so we can just output an
error there into the compiler so that we
actually don't just don't compile and
output that you know output you know for
Apple kind of the same thing here and
also for Linux so that's kind of the
idea with doing this this is the kind of
stuff that I like to see
I mean contributions because this is
this isn't like a major system where
writing these are just a series of
macros to make everything a bit smoother
in terms of compilation and just making
sure that we're not accidentally not
defining the right macros just makes
everything a little bit easier but
doesn't really change massive systems
which is something that we don't want to
really do off camera the other one that
I kind of liked was this check for an
OpenGL version this is something really
really basic but this just basically
assessed that we are using
opengl 4.5 and if we're not it's going
to assert whether or not this is
required again it's questionable because
you might just you know it's just
ultimately you might just let the engine
crash if it's not supported but that's
obviously not a good
do because in that case people might not
know why their copy of the engine is
crashing or why what the trainer on is
crashing whereas here is just gonna tell
you that is because and you're in jail
version is incorrect and that happens
inside OpenGL context which of course is
important because we only want to do
this kind of thing if we're actually
using OpenGL so there's a bunch of stuff
here that you guys should check out
there's also a fix for the orthographic
cameras movement this is something that
I you know I mean I didn't even look
through this I'm not sure I agree with
this to be honest but it is a community
contribution I'll take a little bit more
look here because what this is doing is
um well it's essentially bypassing the
rotation matrix here by just calculating
everything manually using sine and
cosine which probably isn't the best
thing to do but nevertheless it does of
course work and in the future if we need
to actually refine the orthographic
camera we can address that later so this
project is also all about kind of having
a community contribution having a
community develop things me as like the
quote-unquote technical director of this
project I might be inclined to do things
differently right but obviously I can't
let my team which is all of you guys
just completely I can't just be like
sorry guys I just don't like your code
because it's different than what I would
have done unless there's a serious issue
with it you know obviously I should be
here to kind of give technical guidance
as well as potentially steer this engine
into where it's supposed to go but as
far as contributions like this go I kind
of leave that up to you guys if for
example no one agrees with this person
that's why we have a pull requests tab
with a bunch of comments that people can
ride feel free to go to a close pull
request in which something like this
happened right for example here's the
one for orthographic camera controller
movement and then if you don't like this
for example just simply write a comment
being like I don't like this and make
sure you spell life correctly so just do
something like this discuss it doesn't
matter if it's closed you can still
write a comment and we can still kind of
talk about this stuff because obviously
I do want this to kind of be something
you guys
and guess what right if there's ten of
you talking about something you will
probably achieve more than if just one
person just writes an engine by
themselves so this stuff is super
important and there's kind of my hope
with hazel to do kind of more like a
community based project which is exactly
what this is okay cool so that's enough
looking at what you guys have done let's
kind of dive into hazel and then create
that kind of 2d rendering layer which is
what we want to have so that when we
actually start implementing that Duty
renderer we can test everything
appropriately okay so just to take a
little bit of a look at what is we're
going to be doing what we have here if
we just launch the engine is this kind
of example layer inside the sandbox app
door CPP file if we launch it will see
to this which is great this was kind of
the I guess layer that we were talking
about kind of this is like a bit where
we've been testing everything this is
the only layer that the engine has at
the moment which is fine obviously and
we have kind of everything in one file
here we have sandbox which with our
example I have as you can see this stuff
was written to test a whole bunch of
things for example you know we're
creating vertex buffers index buffers
vertex arrays where we've written
shaders here this is all stuff that we
don't actually want to have when we're
testing the 2d renderer or why because
the 2d renderer is gonna be really
simple right all its gonna do is
basically like we're gonna tell it that
we want to start rendering as we
couldn't discuss this and how to in the
how to build a 2d renderer episode which
I'll link in the top right corner but
anyway um we basically just want to be
like hey like renderer we're about to
start rendering stuff here is a triangle
or like here's a quote that wanna render
for example of this color well here's a
bunch of them and then that's it and
then when we finish rendering we kind of
tell the renderer that we're done and
we'd like to see this in the screen
that's the extent of this right it
should ultimately be you know aside from
the camera controller which will still
have you know this stuff render commands
that clear color begin saying begin
saying is something that we will have
but everything else pretty much will not
be here right none of this kind of
setting uniforms none of this you know
binding textures none of these creating
shaders we shouldn't have anything like
that whatsoever but I don't want to
remove this card because if I remove
this car
and when I'm gonna be able to test ill
of the engine very effectively which
obviously we still need to continue
doing so this kind of example I still be
still is part of everything like I don't
want to get rid of that completely but
what I do want to do is basically create
a new layer which is going to be our
kind of I don't know we'll call it like
our our 2d sandbox later all right so
I'll just make a new file called sandbox
2d and then what this will be is kind of
the 2d layer that we need okay so now
we've got both the CPP file and they
have followers include they had a file
in the CPP file if I go back to the
header file we'll just type in class
sandbox sandbox 2g and then we'll have
basically everything that we need inside
here so our goal for today is basically
just to make this work so if we look at
sandbox up it's got example air which is
great I'll keep it in here for now we'll
do push layout new sandbox 2d like that
and then we will of course m-word that
so sandbox treaty ok cool so now we have
that here ultimately we don't need to
push the exam player at all we could
have both layers displaying
simultaneously that's totally fine as
well but for this week we just want to
see everything that example layer has at
the moment we'll still keep it here but
we're not gonna see anything at all okay
so back going back to that sandbox 2d
layer what we definitely want is to have
a what we need to extend layer here is
to be a subclass of layer and then we'll
have will include hazel H which is
important I'll just um yep this of
course needs to be a hazel layer and the
best way to do this is to kind of look
at what example there is and just
basically like steal stuff from there so
what do we need it's a little bit
difficult here because we do have the
implementation along with the definition
or the
the Declaration rather but we definitely
want on update we definitely want online
do we render that's going to be
important and then on event is probably
something that we'll need as well and
then finally usually what happens is
during a layer attachment is what we do
everything in this case we're doing
everything in the constructor which is
also fine
but what I want to do is actually if we
look at layer we have an on attach
function and on and an on detach
function it looks like visuals cheers
got a null reference exception but
hopefully that wasn't anything critical
well my syntax highlighting is gone okay
well visual studio just just have fun
with itself that um doesn't know so
we'll have these functions as well which
is going to be overrides so this is
where we'll do all the initialization so
the Constructors not actually going to
do anything we'll do everything upon
attaching and detaching the layer this
is kind of like our constructor and
destructor but the benefit is that the
layest are kind of has control over that
if we detach a layer we can free all the
resources if we reattach it we don't
need to recreate the layer but we can
just attach it again and that will
construct everything just in case we
want to reuse layers or do anything like
that which is pretty cool okay so now
that we've got that if I just go over to
my CVP file what we'll do is basically
implement this and I will just I was
gonna wait visual assist to that but
like you have even got visual assist
installed I think everything is just
falling apart here which is totally fine
we're gonna continue this episode as if
everything is great because this is the
kind of stuff that happens when you're
developing software sometimes things
don't work and whilst I probably would
take the time to fix it if I was
actually working on stuff not in front
of you guys since this is a video and it
will be slightly awkward for me to just
start messing around with trying to
restart visual studio and doing other
stuff I'm just gonna pretend that
everything is great and just continue on
here I'll like this okay cool so one
more virtual and then by the time I
changed my little monologue you can see
that we're ton which is great
so back in sandbox Apple what is it that
we actually need well again what I would
like to have is something super basic
we have a camera controller you know we
have a shader library we have all of
this stuff in this class which is not
something that we generally need to have
for our new test lair I would like to
render at least something on the screen
just to test that the lair is working
successfully so what I'll do is maybe
I'll just
I could even just do a clear color or
something like this but I probably will
draw something we'll have our
orthographic camera controller because I
think that's important we won't use the
shader library we'll just have a single
shader here which I will read in from a
file I think because we should have we
have a basic texture shader here which
is great so we'll have a shader we'll
have I guess we'll have a texture as
well so I'll steal this and I'll put
this into sandbox 2d what else do we
need here Square color
okay well we'll have square color is
something that we can control in iron
GUI just so that we have something that
we can crop and control inside I am
doing and then you know vertex array
unfortunately we're going to need this
stuff to render at the moment I don't
want to pull over too much stuff as I
mentioned it before because this stuff
is kind of all temporary you know I'll
just kind of make a note here the temp
for all this stuff because this is stuff
that would exist within a 2d renderer
and in fact by doing things this way we
also see what it is we need to basically
abstract away and have inside that 2d
renderer so this this stuff actually
makes building a 2d renderer a lot
easier okay so I'll start dragging over
some other things in the world so for
example on event should call em camera
controller on event with I'm GUI and
settings we can bring over that Square
color as well and we'll have to sort out
the includes here in a minute so we
don't actually need a texture if we're
doing squad color to it you know I'm
going to teach the texture let's go back
to sandbox and just get rid of that
texture we do have a texture shader but
we can probably change that around in a
minute let's see this is also a really
good demonstration I guess Oh actually
what we need to do to make a little
project or a little app in hazel so this
is
gonna kind of give you an idea of how I
would write something like that as well
so yeah unfortunately I'm gonna have to
grab a bunch of this stuff it might be
easier to just grab everything we
definitely don't need the shaders though
to grab like everything and then I'll
just prep everything
I'll grab everything and then I'll start
deleting stuff instead so this goes into
your own attach let's take a look here
vertex array don't reset this stuff
should be I don't know why this stuff is
still at pointa these shall be refs we
in fact why are they like that
so shade is like that I guess we just
haven't done that yet which is strange I
hope that this wasn't something that was
reversed through a pull request I'll
quickly make about X or a a ref like
that so this will return STD make shared
with that time like that and then if we
go back to the H file the header file we
will also make various where's the
create function a ref just like that so
now if we go back to sandbox app we'll
change this to be like that and then in
our sandbox 2d which is over here we'll
also change that
so we're making a vertex array we've
made a bunch of vertices this is not
this is going to be so complicated
are we sitting like these are wrestling
colors here this must be for that
triangle okay cool so I'll probably make
where's that square so we have square
vertices this is probably what we want
to be honest
so maybe what I'll do is just delete all
of this and focus on the square vertex
array so M square V a which is going to
have our square vertices we'll get rid
of the texture coordinates because we
don't really need them and then we have
our square vertex buffer with position
and every corner we'll just have
position we'll keep it nice and simple
for this example square indices will
keep of course
and then the shaders we will delete I do
want to probably move them to a folder
so I'll probably make a new shader here
and I will just call this a flat color
shade up dot yellow cell or this flat
color gel cell it's all excluded from
the project citizens fields and trying
to compile it or anything and then if we
pop back into sandbox today I think
pretty much what I want I'm honestly I'm
just gonna copy the texture shadow call
this the flats color shadow get rid of
everything I don't want which is most
things okay so we do want the view
projection transform because we want the
camera to be able to move but we don't
need texture coordinates that looks good
to me
and then output color and our texture
coordinates will have you color instead
which will be our a uniform vet for and
then we'll just set this like that okay
so that should be okay will support like
alpha and transparency here as well I
guess that looks loosely good to me for
Shadow written in like two seconds
so now we'll delete everything will just
keep the flat color shader and wishes we
actually had that oh cool we do have it
except I used a vector three instead of
effect for here it's the only difference
will delete all this stuff we'll have
our flat color shader which will just be
in this case I think we can just create
it from a file path is that correct yep
so assets shaders and then flats color
GLSL we went to the shredder library or
any off the texture stuff at all cool
and then what I'll do is rename the
shader to be the flat color trader just
sort of where a little bit more clear
here and then I'm doing something we
need so I'll copy and paste that black
college red still seems to be a little
bit sad here don't know why that is and
original she was not telling me I can't
maybe yeah okay it's just intellisense
on detach everything we need to do
anything
in on detach gel and value pointer and
all that stuff comes from here so I'll
just grab these two includes just in
case we probably only need type pointer
not matrix transform but I'll keep
measures transform around just in case
instead render what I want to do is if
we scroll down I want to set the clear
color and clear it we'll have to do a
begin saying I'll copy both scrapple
this kind of like what I did with on
attach it's just easier than jumping
between the files all the time so yeah
this stuff doesn't need to exist for the
flat color shader we definitely need to
so I'll upload that uniform for for
which is you color which is ask our
square color
so what I'll need to do for that is
probably I include the OpenGL shader
which yes we will fix don't worry this
won't be a thing once we finish the 2d
renderer we won't have to do this
this silly dynamic cast thing M Square
color and square color is actually a
effect for now I just thought I'd do
something a little bit different so it's
not completely boring color edit for and
then we've got M square color which is
good after you form the floor floor as
well which is good where need to do
anything yeah all really really all I
want to do is combined the black color
shadow and flash college data bind and
then what we'll do is we'll submit
I guess the flat color shade
well if that's happening and actually
and we found it here so this is an 8 to
exist and I think submit binds it as
well yeah it does so really we don't
need this but we do need to find it yet
just because we do need that you color
uniform to be uploaded there okay and
then what do we need to do so we submit
it with a particular transformation
matrix the camera controller hopefully
has the actual camera stuff in it I
think that's all we need to do so this
is looking pretty as you can see it's a
lot cleaner than what we had inside
sandbox app we haven't tested it yet to
make sure it works but hopefully it will
I don't think I'm missing anything
sandbox app now Lords well is less fixed
let's fix up all the compiler errors we
now have stripped the API changes that I
made sandbox 2d needs I think I I think
it needs a title like a name for the
layout will kind of will still maintain
this stuff so we'll still have a
disruptor yes like just set that equal
to default and then sandbox two days
sorry and then for the constructor we
shoot up through the top we will just do
layer and then sandbox TV ok cool so
that looks pretty good to me
the other issue we have is that
orthographic camera control of course
needs to be set up so we'll just grab a
memory controller here and paste that in
here and I think we should be good to go
so with our layer our sandbox layer
being the ones being pushed
let's here five and we will see what
happens ok so now we're giving you an
error saying that main is already
defined in sandbox 2d now this could be
a tricky error but it's actually a
result of something that we've done
earlier that we shouldn't have done if
you take a look at the hazel header so
if I just open that here by going and go
to document you'll see that we're
including this entry point into every
single CPP file essentially that
includes hazel dot H and since sandbox
2d is in fact including hazel dot H we
are now getting that entry point which
is if we take a look at what entry point
actually is this entry point is an
actual main function and that's being
included everywhere now the solution
here is obviously not to have this here
so this entry point should never be
included we'll get this out of here
I don't know also why syntax
highlighting isn't
because I guess the half of visuals you
get crashed for me through me making
this episode because clearly this card
is too complicated I'm quite surprised
to be honest a visual studio can't
handle this anyway that aside we
basically need to include the entry
point only in the place where the entry
point is actually made his calm and I
guess just to mesh the angular brackets
that's what I'll do here as well so
entry point included in only the place
that it needs to be included in which is
here
um and everything else of course just
includes hazel which does not include
the entry point unless hit f5 again and
hopefully this will now compile and run
successfully okay and as you can see we
have a blue square um if I scroll in and
out that stuff works as well WASD it
seems to work and if I try and change my
Square color that also works which is
pretty cool and we have this kind of
alpha control which you can see we can
also use to kind of fade the square out
because we made it a full component
color so that is our layer complete you
guys can see that it is a really kind of
clean layer that we've created here that
just has everything to render that
little square there as well as a little
camera movement and stuff like that over
the next few episodes were going to be
stripping this stuff out and converting
it into just just render a 2d
essentially which is the beginning of
our 2d rendering in hazel I hope you
guys enjoy this video if you did hit
that like button you can also help
support the series by going to pattern a
gone full slash the chanter as I
mentioned earlier in this video let me
know what you guys think about the
future of hazel in general as I talked
about earlier and I will see you guys in
the next episode
good bye
[Music]